good morning to you I'm Gayle King we're
in the CBS this morning Toyota greenroom
live and in color with radio icon what's
your name yeah I know you really do but
you know it's so funny Delilah I said
I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna do it
cuz I know everybody comes up to you
goes the line can't help it I love it it
doesn't get old to you now never never
no it's done I'll uh millions tune in
every week to hear or give advice to the
love the love Lauren and those who are
really still looking for love in all the
wrong places her off air life is still
full of love to she's a mother of 13
kids I hear soon to be 14 before during
the battles of adopting another one ten
of her children are adopted and in her
new memoir it's called one heart at a
time she opens up about some of the
challenges she's faced over the years
including the loss of her eighteen year
old son Zack to suicide last year
welcome Delilah you write a lot about
Zack tell us his full name I love his
name is Zack and I am Miguel Renee
Ortega or Zack attack
I know Zack attack I like I'm glad that
you can talk about him and smile because
a year is still a short period of time
for something that caused you such pain
but I'm curious about Zack because you
said he knew he was loved he knew that
he was surrounded by people that cared
about him and that it was just a series
of circumstances you say that led him to
take his life well I will convince
tattwas medication that led him to take
his life but it was a series of very sad
circumstances that led us to seek health
that got him on the medication he had
three very traumatic things happen in a
very short period compressed period of
time like what have wrecked his car into
the side of a police officer not good I
did he was driving in a storm totally an
accident was not an on purpose was an
experienced driver in a horrible storm
but he thought he had killed or injured
the man terribly because he hit his head
and there was a lot of blood and he
never drove again even though the man
was fine it was very tiring to you it
was so jarring that he thought
he hurt somebody he never drove again
which limited his life because his
father and I lived like it was an hour
and a half driving that it's three hours
by public transportation so that altered
his life he moved out of the farm where
he had lived his whole life he really
wanted to spend his senior year with his
dad but he did fear in his dad were no
longer together
yeah we divorced when he was before he
was walking so he had never really spent
as much time with his dad as he had
hoped to but he didn't realize he Zack
was very social he was the life of the
party he was you said he was a live wire
from the time from mid-morning about
reading about him because one day he
invited 40 people over for lunch yeah we
were there was African children's choir
performing at our church and after they
performed the director came up to me and
said Delilah that was so nice of you I
said what was so nice yeah he said to
invite us to lunch I said what are you
talking about that said that we were
invited to your farm for lunch and we
don't have any plans for lunch so that's
and with the adults it was like 52
people yeah something crazy coming to
the house I'm like ah no you know when I
was reading I was so frightened because
right up he he took his life October 2nd
but leading up to the days he was making
plans he was he was making plans about
the dentist he was making plans about
going to school that's why I always say
to people sometimes these things happen
without any warning we can't say oh I
knew that something that he was upset or
sad well we like I said he had these
things happen
and so in January there was a crisis he
missed two weeks of school because it
was gravely ill
he missed school which meant he wasn't
going to graduate with his class and
that was the third you know girl trouble
car and and he went into a depression
and so his dad and I did everything in
our power thinking we were doing the
right things we got him to a doctor we
got him to a counselor wonderful
counselor and she had a session with
them three days before those but York
and it's medication I know it's
medication but why
he left he left a nine page letter and
there was no mention of sorrow no
mention of loneliness no mention of
sadness it was insane ramblings
it was the writing of a crazy person
mm-hmm about time travel in deja vu and
he said time is a river and I am able to
enter and exit the river's edge anytime
I want
so you'd never seen that kind of
nonsensical it was all completely
nonsensical and so everybody's like whoa
he must have been on some crazy and I'm
like no no I know my son he wasn't on
crazy are you comfortable talking about
what the drug was no no I can't you
don't want to say what the drug was but
it was that what you've learned about
this drug is very troubling so when the
toxicology report came back he was on
nothing he had quit taking his
antidepressant looks like about 10 days
before mm-hmm he told a couple of people
young people who never said anything
that that the side effects were killing
him and so there was no no marijuana no
alcohol and that's why I know because I
know my son he wasn't crazy gale he was
a lot of things but when you look into
the research about this particular drug
you see other people I think the doctor
told you you know three other teenagers
were all coroner did who handled that's
why it's frightening to me yes and so
the research that we did and I went kind
of insane I went I went over the deep
end oh because I found out that the
medicine that had been given him the
drug makers know that in young people
under 25 years old 47% of the time
causes more suicidal ideation 47 I'm
like pulling my hair out going that's
not possible how can you sell a medicine
that and I went to pick to that but I
wouldn't fill the prescription I said to
him every day did you take your meds
check it out
take your meds not realizing 47% of the
time you think you're helping him I
thought I was helping my son then
Delilah
why aren't you comfortable saying what
the medication
I don't wanna lose it okay but what
should investigate what you're talking
about that's why I want to talk to you
about this isn't very very scary to me
the the drug company hid the research
for several years when it was exposed
they were fined and forced to put a
black box warning which means what which
is a little black box it's like two
inches by three inches that says that on
the on the on the on the Bravo if you
take this please know that there have
been increase in suicidal ideation
homicidal ideation and delusions as most
people don't read the black ball I never
saw have the black box he was eighteen
yeah he was eighteen and here's the
other crazy thing in our country if
you're over 18 your parents have no
input in your medical care so here he
was depressed he knew he was depressed
we knew he was depressed he was very
open about it he was very open with his
counselor about his depression we think
we're helping him by taking him into a
doctor who puts him on a medication that
we have no knowledge of no information
about and my bad for not doing the
research beforehand but I have medically
fragile children you have children that
have asthma I have children that have
sickle-cell I had a child that had
sickle cell so I'm used to filling
prescriptions yeah are you considering
legal action no in this particular no I
just want people to know that if you are
diagnosed with depression or your child
is do the research before you take
medication
yeah because had I done the research had
his father done the research and his dad
is a very very very smart man mm-hmm
he researches as are you thank you sir
you delay the two of us together never
knew yeah it had no clue we thought we
were helping that we were giving him a
poison mm-hmm and and that's why I think
it's so important that you're at least
sharing this part of your life and your
story that while you're reluctant to say
the medication if someone's going
through this please do the research and
please read them less lately if you're
under 25 yeah especially if you are
under 20 yeah
what did Zach teach
you say in your book he taught you
patience yeah ed Zack taught me Zack had
13 broken bones before he was 13 years
old how in the world is that he was born
with no fear factor do you he could
scale anything and he didn't feel pain
the way you and I do yeah so little
things like this yeah he had sensory
integration problems so this would drive
him nuts a gentle soft touch but jumping
off a staircase and breaking his
collarbone at 3 years old
he didn't even cry yeah if it weren't
for the fact that his arm was hanging
limp by his side we wouldn't have even
known and you said he taught you to look
deeper I
he definitely taught me to love deeper
Zach loved intensely and without
condition or reservation his his friends
every day yeah his friends are the best
young people people talk about you know
how young people are this our young
people are that let me tell you young
people are awesome and his best friends
his circle of friends are so good to me
you have a beautiful story in the book
about a teacher who talked to you about
Zack how about how Zack was always
looking out for other kids in the class
that I thought was very moving always
very indicative of who he was as a
person yeah there was there was a friend
at a guy in the cafeteria even yeah I
just heard you love that story about his
mom that he's got a really good job so
Steven was a young boy he came to my
house after the services and he said you
can probably tell I'm a little goofy I'm
like you look like a wonderful young man
to me he goes I was awkward and he said
that his family was going through stuff
and he didn't have any money for lunch
and he said your son saw me sitting
alone in the cafeteria and he came and
sat down next to me and said dude what's
up why the long face yeah and he said I
was embarrassed to say I was hungry yeah
and he's you know maybe he's he made
light of it and he says ACK disappeared
and five minutes later he came back with
a tray of food and my personal assistant
Joni was always kind of going
head-to-head with Zack because Zack
would like to lock horns and she came
home and she said do you got a you got
to get on Zack he's running a scam I'm
some sort of I'm like what are you
talking about she says his lunch money
is gone yeah I put in enough money for
the whole month and it's gone in like
two weeks and so I confronted Zack and I
said are you like whatever it's going on
he was like mom it's you know I I'm just
eaten a lot I guess you know he didn't
even want to give up his friend yeah
never I'm a show-off if I were that age
and I did something nice I'd want
attention for it not Zack that's it not
Zack not Zack and this young man said
not only did he you know get me lunch he
became my friend and he said before you
know it all of his cool friends are
hanging out with me and he said he he
made me feel loved so that has to
comfort you in some way to know that you
raised a son that had such a
compassionate heart to look out for
other people till I as painful as this
is that has to give you and make you
smile knowing the joy that he brought to
others it did I smile I didn't even know
Zack and I just thought he and you tell
many stories about him in the book I
should say I smiled thinking what a
great kid what a great he was is an
amazing kid I mean there's so many
stories and after he passed there's a
little funeral home in our small town
that said you know you can come and
spend as much time as you want and his
friends came and you know the funeral
home director I'm sure thought we were
gonna be there an hour to go we stayed
all day I believe it and story after
story and before you know it were
howling laughing here's my son's body it
was weird but just the stories of silly
things he did and loving things he did
and crazy things he did I'm like how did
it even make it 18 well how didn't even
think it 18
Dalila you were his mom that's how he
made it to 18 let me tell you if there's
something if there's something you know
it's about mothering we said in the
beginning that you have 13 children
you're about to adopt another one that
would make 14 10 who were adopted and
you talk in the book about your life I
got a big kick out of you two because
you just said you were a show-off you
write about being a show I'm such a
show-off know what I was born with the
show-off game well you said I didn't
have the let's see athletic skills the
math ball can't dribble a ball but what
you couldn't throw a frisbee for the dog
but but what you could do I didn't mean
to kick you but what you could do is
talk you were always a very good talker
I was a very good talker so how nice and
you earn your living talking how nice
yeah how nice and for the teacher that
tape my mouth shot and third with duct
tape ah yeah yeah okay yeah because you
were talking too much constantly when
did you know because I think your voice
is so unique you probably don't think so
or maybe you do now but you have such a
unique voice and I discovered you you
know over 20-something years ago when I
was commuting back and forth from
Connecticut to New York and and living
in Connecticut I would listen to you at
night I would like to say that I
personally have added six limo drivers
to your repertoire oh thank you yeah
you're welcome Sam put it on Delilah I
would say put it on July and they go
what is this and then they would start
listening and then they then I'd get in
the car they go I was listening to her
the other day she was telling the
different stories I'm always I'm always
fascinated by the men by the men that
certainly start listening I was
listening her the other day and before I
knew it I had tears running down my face
because you have a unique way of telling
a story and matching a song with a story
but when did you know that you had this
Unni I'm very fascinated by your voice I
never knew that I never knew that
and my voice you know it now though my
voice has been this deep since I was a
little girl and my mom used to tell the
story that should be like in a grocery
store and not only did I have a
different voice I was big I was like
this tall in seventh grade yeah you're
510 yeah and I was a big little girl
uh-huh
and mom said you were five ten and seven
yeah wow that is tall yeah and the boys
were like five nothing no I was just I
had that I lived in Turkey as a kid and
I was in fifth grade taller than
everybody and you'd have to line up
uh-huh and I'd be taller than all the
boys and they would call me goofy gale
goofy gale and so to this day to this
day I I said to myself I used to want to
be little and petite now I'm not and I'm
glad I'm not but to this day I have this
hang-up about I like guys who are taller
than me do you have that hang-up or no
no you don't I just like guys they're
shorter than you that's okay that was
okay yeah my husband Zach's dad was much
sort of not much sort of the neighbor he
was shorter you also said that you were
very attracted to radio which lucky for
us because you have such a good voice
but there was one director one boss who
said to you you know women don't really
like listening to other women talk
research had told him that research that
research there you go this is like 15
years into my career
yeah where I've talked to thousands tens
of thousands probably hundreds of
thousands of women on the phone a
conference of speaking engagements and I
was in my 30s I was a mother of two and
he was in his 20s and he's sitting there
definitively telling me to [ __ ] this is
what the research shows you need to shut
up and play the music was and you said
it's really better what you did I I
reached into my pocket book and I
removed something it's a tampon she
removed okay good I said I think of that
visual people okay you touch that
tampons and when you have to get up at 3
o'clock in the morning and and go to the
store because you're out of these and
you're bleeding to death and you can
tell me what women either want but until
then you don't really have a clue did
you still keep your job no because you
write that you've been fired by the time
you were 21 you had been fired how many
times were you three or four times by
the time you were thirty you had been
fired quite a bit more eight eight times
but despite all of that up to 12 but my
and then you stop counting but despite
all of that that never deterred you
Delilah why the the only thing I can
take credit for I can't take credit from
my voice God gave me that I can't take
credit for my personality God gave me
that the only thing that I can take
credit for is if you knock me down I
might take a minute to lick my wounds
yeah and to catch my breath but I will
get up and when I get up I will defeat
you I will I will defeat you
and nothing will stop me you knock me
down I take a minute might take an hour
might even take a day or two yeah to
catch my breath and cry and I mean I got
fired one time in Philly and I sat there
with a straight face took it went in the
bathroom laid out on the floor on the
floor doing the ugly cry genius even had
found me a baby the producer my producer
I want to meet her yes and it's just
like what's going on is we just got
fired again and I was a wreck but you
know to his face I was cool you would
take it so if you're thinking about
adopting another child which would be 14
clearly children give you a lot of joy
in your life they do it's what I'm best
at there are a lot of things I'm not
good at and you go to Africa you go to
places that aren't in the United States
you adopt kids with special needs what
is that about you well what do you smile
I only set out believe it or not to
adopt one dude yeah I got a home study
after Shayla was born before Shayla was
born after Sonny was born my firstborn I
was a single mom for 10 years and after
he was born the doctor said it's not
gonna happen again I had polycystic
ovaries and other health problems they
said it's not gonna happen again so I
tried to adopt a little boy we lived in
Boston he was placed with us had him for
three months peanut and then the birth
mother came back in the picture she had
lost six children to the state but in
our broken deplorable foster care system
you can pretty much kill a kid and they
will still give it a head back to you
your mother yeah yeah
and so they by law had to give her
another chance and so he was taken from
us and that was really devastating how
old was he at the time this peanut was
18 months and Sonny was eight so it was
enough for you to get attached oh yeah
yeah oh yeah so you said okay I will
adopt another child so I waited for a
while and then I married my dog my kid's
father and we were blessed with Shayla
which was a miracle yes she was a
surprise yeah there's a beautiful
wonderful awesome miracle but I wanted
more kids I had two I wanted three or
four and so we set about adopting and I
wanted to do something that's called
twinning in the adoption world where you
adopt a child is within a year or two of
your own natural child so I we found a
boy in foster care Emmanuel who was a
year younger than my son applied madam
loved him fell in love with him the
first day we met him he was 11 got
custody of him and then found out he had
siblings in foster care yes you can't
just adopt him and not his sibling so
how many siblings so many well he has a
lot but there were two in foster care
uh-huh and I wrote about it in the book
we went camping and his little brother
who was nine at the time reaches out
Gail in the middle of the night and the
tent grabs my hand I says are you awake
I said yeah he says can I call you mama
since I don't have a mama hmm that's a
wrap that was a wrap that put me over so
set about adopting the siblings got
custody of them so I went from two
children to five children in six months
and then I sent them to summer camp with
the church and at for almost 40 years
old got pregnant was lakatamia Zach
attack yeah like how you call him that
yeah he was a Zach attack I mean he
attacked life he lived life so fully so
completely so totally well you feel that
and you also said he's most like you you
talk very candidly about your you
married several times you know some
people say okay if you try it once you
try it twice it doesn't work that's it
and my Angela had been married many
times and we would say how many and she
refused to tell us because she said that
doesn't matter that doesn't matter what
it but what happened is in the past that
was out of what she said yeah my mom
used to kind of argue with me sometimes
and I say mama why do you choose to
remember those things that I choose to
forget why don't you just remember the
ones I want you to remember but you've
been married four times do you always
believe that love is possible I do do
you always believe that I do
I believe that too I do I do I'm a
hopeless romantic I believe that every
pot has a lid that there is somebody
that will fit perfectly into your life
who will love you unconditionally just
the way you are where do we go to find
these pots in these little yes I went to
the gym this time I met I met Doug my
kid's dad at church and he's a wonderful
human being but our lives kind of took
different different trajectories anyway
ah you believe there's a pot for
everybody I believe and you never guy
believed you desire that there are some
people that have no desire whatsoever to
be partnered mm-hmm but there are if you
desire a partner I think that desire
comes from God and that he doesn't give
you that desire without meeting it long
before you're born mm-hmm he didn't give
me the desire to be a mother without the
way to meet it mm-hmm and you know I
struggled with infertility before Shayla
was born yeah and was happy to adopt
anyway I adopted Manny that was the one
that I got a home study for and plan to
adopt every other child that I have
adopted since God brought into my life
and presented a situation where I had an
option to say yes or say no you do but
it wasn't that I went out looking I
didn't go out so it's not like I brought
all these kids at you
to my home or my world because I needed
them God brought them to me because they
needed stability I know yours your
philosophy is about living simply which
doesn't seem to me how a person that
does what you do is living simply then
you don't buy anything new and that you
don't owe this jackets actually new Oh
Bravo yeah yeah just for you yeah well
it's very nice 99% of the item okay that
I represent you said you don't buy
anything new you don't you've never been
to Saks is that really true that is true
I didn't I didn't believe through Saks
Fifth Avenue the department store yeah a
goodwill and st. Vinnie's and thrift
stores are my Saks
yeah I've always been thrifty because my
parents were my grandparents survived
the Great Depression mm-hmm and so they
brought that into my parents thank you
okay and then my father taught me at
Yale when I was young he had say sis
don't ever go into debt if you go into
debt you got to work for the man yeah if
you don't go into debt you can tell them
to kiss your hand
and that that that resonated with you
and it still stays with you today oh
hell yes have you been do you have you
ever been to Macy's I have been to me do
you know they have on the like third or
fourth floor a section where everything
is like 75% off yes I do I love that did
on that floor so the motto for Delilah
is love love you say Trump's everything
love trumps everything but not just a
romantic love I mean really that's what
my show is a lot of times people think
my show is about but the book that I
wrote the show that I do the life that I
live I believe and the reason I wrote
the book one heart at a time I believe
we can change the world we need to stop
looking to politicians looking to
policies looking to programs to change
the world and we need to be the change
in the world yeah and we can do that one
harder that's at a time and it's
not that oh that we're going to get on a
platform you've got an amazing platform
I've been blessed with an amazing
platform but the best work that I've
done in my life and I know the best work
that you've done in your life is through
entering into relationships and giving
of ourselves and we we live in a society
that's very narcissistic and
self-centered yeah we want to be
pleasure we want to be pleased yeah we
want pleasure we want football we want
and we want it now yeah we want it now
we want it quickly we want I love it
Amazon you know we want it delivered a
little harder when you live out the
country but we want it now we want what
we want when we want it and that is so
completely opposite of what's best for
us so I think we should take your
philosophy one heart one heart at a time
we can work miracles one heart at a time
we can it's a pleasure to really meet
you thank you as I've so loved and
admired you for a very long time thank
you yeah thank you for getting the
drivers to listen yeah yes
six-six-six so far that'll do it with me
and Lyla do you know that's my daughter
that sings that it is it is